este sábado olímpico francia tiene tres
finales ya disputó la primera la final
masculina de baloncesto con una victoria
para eeuu 82 87 los dirigidos por gregg
popovich y no jugaron su mejor partido
pero sí fueron lo suficientemente
eficaces para alzarse con el oro y sobre
todo con un kevin durant capitán del
equipo quien marcó 29 puntos y con esto
los estadounidenses se quedan por cuarta
vez consecutiva con la medalla de oro en
un torneo olímpico mientras que los
franceses se quedaron con la medalla de
plata las otras dos finales que tienen
los galos pues una es ante dinamarca
esto es en balonmano los franceses que
van a por ese título olímpico que ya
habían conseguido tanto en beijing como
en londres ante una selección danesa
pues que parte como favorita son los
campeones del mundo y desde que lograron
ese título en 2019 han sido más que
hegemónicos y por otra parte la otra
final que se disputa prácticamente a la
misma hora que esta del balonmano es la
de voleibol francia que clasificó por
primera vez a la final del torneo de
voleibol en unos juegos olímpicos se
enfrentan al comité olímpico ruso los
rusos que parten como claros favor